madame à libé bonsoir bonsoir alors
d'abord félicitations c'est à
fonctionner qu est-ce qui est ce qui
vous vous étiez créative pourquoi
exactement là mais c'est la première
fois qu'on a fait un vol sur une autre
planète donc vols contrôlés sur une
autre planète ce qui est spécial avec la
planète mars et que pour la grève des
chômeurs c'est juste un tiers de latin
donc on est un petit peu plus légiste
sur mars mais l'atmosphère injuste 1%
dans l'atmosphère de la terre ça veut
dire qu'il ya vraiment pas beaucoup
d'air c'est l'air quand on vole qui nous
pousse qui nous soulève donc vraiment se
demander est ce que c'est possible de
voler sur mars on savait bon qu'on avait
fait nausicaa des équations qu'on
pensait qu'on allait être capable mais
aujourd'hui avoir accompli ça ça nous
aimons vraiment que oui c'est possible
de voler sur mars
c'est possible de contrôler quelque
chose comme ça sur une autre planète
dessau boverie énormément de portes dans
l'exploration de deux planètes
mais comment on a fait justement comme
l'atmosphère est beaucoup plus légères
comme en affaires est-ce que les balles
étaient plus longs il semble que non
comme on l'a fait pour que ça vole mais
en fait oui les pales sont quand même
assez grands tels fonds 1.2 m le chacune
et l'hélicoptère lui même donc le corps
de les copains d'enfance et la grosseur
d'une voire deux mouchoirs mais ça pèse
environ 1.8 kg
on compense des grosses perles un petit
corps c'est ce qui nous permet de voler
il est pâle aussi ton très très
rapidement et c'est ce qui nous permet
justement de voler sur balles vous aviez
mais un petit bout de l'avion des frères
hunt le premier vol parce que pour vous
c'est vraiment une première qu'il faut
souligner la wii c'est justement c'est
là ça fait honneur au fret qui ont fait
le premier vote sur terre il ya à peine
une centaine d'années c'est quand même
fou de dire qu'on s'entend on a passé
deux pas des vols comme ça sur la terre
et l'on se rend sur une autre planète
attire 1 et le capteur sinopec et de
voler somare sont que oui pour nous
c'est vraiment une grosse première c'est
la première fois qu'on a fait ce genre
de vol sur nos palettes et ça va comme
les frères bêtes ont été reconnus sur
terre en aviation
un jour je pense qu'on va parler des
lignes ou éthique comme le premier vol
voilà je le disais ça dure et 39
secondes vous allez essayer de le rendre
le plus complexe possible quoi oui c'est
exactement non encore quelques quelques
semaines de plus pour faire notre
démonstration technologie on essaie de
faire au moins cinq vols donc et chacun
va être de plus en plus compliqué de
plus en plus ambitieux donc le prochain
vol on espère en plus de monter ont noté
aujourd'hui on est juste et dont on est
montés pour défiler sans doute on essaie
de voyager en horizontal aussi monté un
peu plus haut des choses comme ça et
éventuellement on espère se rendre
encore plus loin justement prenantes en
apprendre le plus possible le temps que
cette démonstration technologies et
côtiers
quelles répercussions ces vols low
pourrait avoir sur la terre pour les
hélicoptères de la terre par exemple
mais je pense que les choses qu'on
apprend quand on veut sur mars c'est
comment faire tout automatiquement
comment faire des décisions à bord
d'hélicoptères fera atterrir
parce que mars est tellement loin que
l'on veut pas faire des opérations en
temps réel
donc ça ça peut nous aider aussi sur
terre un jour cette technologie peut
nous aider justement faire des
opérations dans les environnements où
les humains ne peut pas fall et ne
peuvent pas faire ces interactions avec
les robots au niveau de l'autonomie de
l'automatisation c'est déjà un domaine
dans lequel on avance donc au c'est sûr
qu'on apprend toujours des choses comme
ça en robotique on peut ramener sur
terre
et bien sûr qu'on peut aller sur
d'autres planètes heures jour quand on
veut continuer ce genre d'exploration
par ailleurs fera libérer nous reste une
minute trente
comment se porte la mission en général
sur mars mais le tout va super bien sûr
mars donc justement dans les premiers ça
fait exactement presque 2 2 mois la
choriste sur mars
donc le premier mois et demi s'est
consacré à fantômes et chacun de l'astro
mobile on a bougé le bras vous avez vu
les belles photos qu'on a pris on peut
conduire n'ont fait notre démonstration
technologie et une fois que ce c'est
fini on va commencer à conduire
justement vers le delta de la rivière
dans l'ancienne rien dans lequel on a
adhéré
on espère dans les prochaines mois
prendre le premier échantillon
l'addition persévérance et de recueillir
des échantillons pour m
sur terre donc tout avance bien on est
super occupé sur terre sur le saut mars
même si bien donc je n'ai pas trouvé
encore le signe de ville n'ont pas
encore le sait justement on commence à
chercher mais vraiment ce qui est
important pour nous c'est de trouver ces
échantillons intéressant là de voyager
dans différents environnements sommet
parce qu'on veut ramener justement si
l'échantillon là pour chercher pour
cécile les villes phares à libé c'est
toujours un plaisir ingénieurs en héros
spatial à la nasa
merci beaucoup nous avons parlé et merci
ça fait plaisir
au revoir